bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
remise du rapport de la commission
d'enquêté parlementaire sur la corse les
carences de l'état sont soulignés
présentation en conseil des ministres du
budget de la france 99 et câlins avec un
objectif l'emploi monsieur jacques
chirac rappelle ses critiques sur la
gestion socialiste dominique strauss
kahn vis de l'économie à notre invité
suite du travail judiciaire dans les
affaires de dopage concernant le
cyclisme témoignage du soigneur belge de
l'équipe festina c'est par lui que tout
a commencé
une nouvelle chanson réflexion de michel
sardou qu'est ce que j'aurais fait moi
une interrogation sur la période
d'occupation michel sardou est également
notre invité en direct dans ce journal
c'est en début d'après midi que le
premier ministre a reçu de jean glavany
président la commission d' enquête sur
la corse
un rapport de 600 pages rédigées après
six mois d'enquêté celle ci commence à
peu de temps après l'assassinât du
préfet claude érignac le 6 février
dernier ajaccio ce que l'on sait de ce
rapport dans ses conclusions ressemble à
une mise en cause des carences des
différents pouvoirs dans l'île notamment
de l'état et de ses représentants le
rapport parlementaire relève les fraudes
les pratiques abusives et l'inconstance
des politiques menées en corse depuis un
quart de siècle
voici quelques éléments de ce rapport
commenté par olivier galzi avec alban
nicosie est pire laurent constant 600
pages sur l'utilisation des fonds
publics en corse où les mots aux dérives
fraude et laxisme reviennent le plus
souvent
les responsables de la commission
denquête remettent leur rapport au
premier ministre en cause les élus
locaux mais aussi l'état
premier dossier particulièrement visés
l'agriculture
de nombreux agriculteurs aujourd'hui au
bord de la faillite ont subi un système
et ne l'ont pas choisi la responsabilité
du crédit agricole qui a développé une
politique de prêts tous azimuts épatante
montré du doigt donc le crédit agricole
coupable d'un mécanisme de cavalerie
très coûteux pour les finances publiques
dans un univers où le non paiement était
la règle et où l'argent est distribué
avec une facilité apparente les
cotisations sociales ont été la dernière
obligation à laquelle les plus gros
débiteurs de la caisse régionale du
crédit agricole
ce serait conforme ainsi les dettes se
sont accumulées au fil des ans et
aujourd'hui la caisse de développement
de la corse est incapable de recouvrer
ses créances
une ardoise de plus d'un milliard de
francs deuxième cible du rapport la
justice avec des témoignages implacable
la justice que j'ai vu fonctionner
encore ce n'était pas ma justice ni
serait ni efficace ni impartiale le
comportement de la justice en corse
depuis 30 ans est lamentable un
magistrat entendu par la commission d'
enquête a même comparé cette justice de
lille à un bateau ivre où règnerait la
connivence l'intimidation et la
désillusion
enfin troisième volet marquant de ce
rapport celui des subventions celui de
la responsabilité de l'état
il faut que soit définitivement
abandonné l'idée que la paix civile
s'achète tout se vend
la responsabilité de l'état la fois
politiques administratives et lourdes
un constat sans concession sur l'action
de l'état en corse
chiffres à l'appui la solidarité
nationale dont bénéficie lille s'élève à
près de 3 milliards de francs par an
soit 11 mille cinq cents francs par
habitant
le prix de l'apaisement dénonce le
rapport comme si l'état de droit pouvait
s'acheter donc de multiples infractions
voir scandales financiers ont été mises
au jour en corse depuis plusieurs mois
alors ce soir nous proposons l'histoire
édifiante du port de propriano reportage
claude samper et patrick das muhly
propriano une petite commune de 3000
habitants au sud d'ajaccio
l'un des plus grands scandales
financiers sur lequel s'est penché la
commission denquête des députés en 1989
et milwaukee le maire décide d'agrandir
son port de plaisance
une étude de l'administration estime les
travaux à 23 millions de francs
la commune confie le chantier dans des
circonstances peu claires à la société 8
offshore pour 41 millions de francs
en 1994 un rapport de police dénonce le
scandale
aujourd'hui seul le premier adjoint a
accepté de nous rencontrer
c'est le premier fait connaissez bien
communal à vous savez si la commission
d' enquête parlementaire qui va rendre
son rapport jeudi matin est venue dans
la commune pour se pencher sous licence
je vous confirme donc je n'ai pas vu moi
je sais pas mais pourtant d'après nos
informations ils sont bien venus ici
pour enquêter
vous n'êtes pas grand premier mensonge
la sphère du port de propriano on en est
où alternent pour primates un creux des
mains de la justice
mon avis personnel c'est que il a dit
qu'il n'y a jamais rien eu de le décor
des nerfs dessus tout a été fait dans
les normes d'un règles de conformité des
noirs
deuxième mensonge ici toutes été
surfacturés exemple à tonnes de béton à
800 francs lui de 580 le prix normal et
le projet prévoyait même la création
d'une route parce que c'est route elle
est construite ou pas et c'est tout cet
intérêt d'aller bien sûr qu'elles
étaient construites cet euro et elle
fait partie maintenant de de la faire la
route était construite 1
la route était qu'on souhaitait vous la
voyez la lll borde le le port de
plaisance témoin j'ai du mal à voir
elle est recouverte de poussière une
route recouverte de poussière en fait un
véritable chemin de terre la mairie
avait effectivement prévu ici la
création d'une route pour desservir ce
port de plaisance
coût total des travaux 6 millions de
francs qui devait être financée pour
moitié par la mairie pour moitié par le
rogue l'argent de la cee est bien arrivé
jusqu'ici ce problème la route
comme vous pouvez le voir n'a jamais été
construite et c'est tout simplement ce
qu'on appelle un détournement d'argent
public
un détournement de fonds que le rapport
parlementaire dénonce haut et fort avant
la fin de l'année la justice devrait
renvoyer le maire de la commune devant
le tribunal correctionnel puis à noter
que le président du centre départemental
des jeunes agriculteurs a été interpellé
ce matin et que le dirigeant
nationaliste corse françois santoni
emprisonné à paris depuis 18 mois a fait
savoir qu'il démissionnait du parti
indépendantiste à concoules conseil des
ministres ce matin les visaient avec la
présentation du projet de loi de
finances pour 1999 c'est à dire le
budget de la france pour l'année
prochaine ce projet repose sur une
prévision de croissance de 2 7%
dans le détail il ya certaines baisses
de taxes mais globalement pour ceux qui
paient l'impôt sur le revenu à savoir
moins d'un français sur deux qui aura
pas de changement et pourtant les
recettes de l'état seront en
augmentation
l'explication jean-paul chapelle
grâce à la croissance 53 milliards de
francs supplémentaires devraient rentrer
l'an prochain dans les caisses de l'état
des fruits récoltés sans effort répartis
dans trois directions habituellement
inconciliables
d'abord combler les trous le déficit de
l'etat sera réduit de 21 milliards de
francs
les fameux 3% de déficits publics vont
tomber à 2 3% l'an prochain
deuxièmement la croissance permette à
l'état d'augmenter son train de vie plus
16 milliards de francs essentiellement
des augmentations de salaires négociés
par les fonctionnaires enfin grâce au
surplus l'état diminuent dans le même
temps certaines taxes 16 milliards de
francs en tout pas de baisse de l'impôt
sur le revenu les ménages devront se
contenter d'une tva réduite sur
l'abonnement et des fdf et -20% sur les
frais de notaire pour ceux qui achètent
un logement
la taxe professionnelle sur les salaires
sera supprimé en cinq ans un cadeau aux
entreprises présenté comme une aide à
l'emploi alors devant les ministres
monsieur jacques chirac le président la
république a rappelé sa position sur ce
que devrait être la politique budgétaire
de la france il a marqué sa différence
en voici trois extraits nous devons
c'est ma conviction choisir de réduire
résolument les impôts qui pèsent sur les
français et leur entreprise
nous devons choisir de réduire les
dépenses de l'état
et puis enfin dans un autre extrait des
propos de monsieur jacques chirac il
nous faut faire le meilleur usage de nos
marges de manoeuvre citation donc de
propos tenus par monsieur chirac en
conseil des ministres ce matin ans
gérard leclerc l'impression que comme le
14 juillet dernier dans son intervention
télévisée monsieur chirac se pose un peu
en chef de l'opposition
en tout cas en marquant clairement sa
différence avec le gouvernement jacques
chirac vise une triple cohérence
cohérence avec sa fonction le président
existe qu'il joue pleinement son rôle en
s'exprimant au nom de ce qu'il pense
être l'intérêt du pays
cohérence avec ses convictions le chef
de l'état lève toute ambiguïté ce n'est
pas son budget ce ne sont pas ses choix
comme il l'avait déjà exprimé l'an
dernier lors du même exercice et plus
récemment dans son intervention du 14
juillet enfin cohérence avec
l'opposition dont il apparaît un peu
plus la référence est l'inspirateur il
donne le ton et les arguments critiques
qui seront repris par tous les leaders
rpr udf et démocratie libérale tout en
se gardant fonction oblige de s'exprimer
dans un registre politiciens alors du
coup lionel jospin ne répondra pas ni
matignon ni les socialistes ne se fût ce
que de cette intervention qu'il qualifie
même de banal et sans surprise même
courtoise à cohabitation réunit deux
forces politiques opposées
d'où ce marquage au plus près entre le
président et le premier ministre qui
rappelle celui qui avait exercé de 1986
à 1988
sous mitterrand sur jacques chirac avant
que l'élection présidentielle ne
départage des deux hommes on verra tout
à l'air sévère réaction dessus strauss
kahn ja à droite en tout cas monsieur
jean louis debré a ironisé sur le talent
de magiciens de monsieur strauss kahn
alain madelin a parlé d'un budget en
trompe l'oeil monsieur de charette par
d'imprudence et françois d'aubert
d'occasions manquées quant à la cgt son
secrétaire général louis joinet estime
que les grands gagnants de ce budget
sont les entreprises et puis le cnc le
cnpf par la voix de monsieur caisse
claire a affirmé qu'il faut traiter le
problème des charges et ensuite nous
aurons l'emploi trois autres
commentaires politiques à suivre
assemblée par véronique saint olive
c'est un projet de budget qui me prépare
pas l'avenir on augmente fortement les
dépenses publiques
on ne propose pas de baisses d'impôts on
parie sur des recettes de la croissance
alors que la croissance aujourd'hui est
menacée par ce qui se passe en russie et
par ce qui se passe en asie
on nous refait en fait la même chose
qu'à l'époque du gouvernement rocard on
dépense avant que l'argent ne sont
rentrés dans la pièce et demain nous ne
payerons draps des chômeurs de plus ce
que je reproche à la politique du
gouvernement
non seulement c'est de ne pas avoir
prévu ce retournement de croissance mais
d'avoir par avance gaspiller les
recettes de la croissance en dépenses
nouvelles
quand les recettes fiscales
supplémentaires ne seront plus là les
dépenses restaurant je note que les
objectifs sont positifs ce qui a été
énoncé c'est d'asseoir la croissance sur
la relance de la consommation et
l'investissement dans les entreprises
cela dit je crains pour ma part que les
moyens pour atteindre ses objectifs soit
un tantinet modeste je trouve que ce qui
est évoqué par exemple sur la tva tient
davantage du symbole que vraiment de la
capacité à relancer le pouvoir d'achat
de mx ozcan bonsoir soit votre réaction
propos de jacques chirac vous avez
l'impression de vous faire réprimander
non ce n'est pas le rôle du président la
république de réprimander le
gouvernement et la république dit qu'il
faut baisser les impôts on est tous
d'accord qu'il faut essayer de réduire
les déficits on est tous d'accord
d'ailleurs nous le faisons les
gouvernements qui nous présente précédé
dont il se sentait plus proche n'ont pas
toujours fait néanmoins il faut aller
dans le sens là et je crois que s'il
nous incite à aller plus vite encore
dans le sens là c'est finalement il est
peut-être pas tellement d accord il
trouve ça pas si mal
enfin ils rappellent commun qu'il
faudrait créer dépenses publiques baïsse
le plus vite
oui mais honnêtement c'est facile de
dire ça quand on n'a pas les manettes
mais quand des gouvernements qui étaient
proches de lui étaient au pouvoir les
dépenses publiques ne baissez pas
pourquoi est ce que dépense publique ne
baisse pas parce qu'il ya des choses à
financer a été votée en 98 une noire
contre l'exclusion
ça entraîne des dépenses l'année 99 il
faut les mettre en oeuvre ces dépenses
si la pays ne veut pas qu'ils aient des
exclus et s'il veut mettre en oeuvre des
solutions pour leur venir en aide il
faut bien les payer
à l'arrivée les dépenses publiques
très peu elle augmente très peu ce qui
permet justement la baisse du déficit ça
a été rappelé dans notre reportage et la
baisse des impôts et là je veux insister
une seconde là dessus quand même parce
que c'est pas si souvent que les infos
baisse notent avec pour pour le commun
des mortels ces impôts vont pas baisser
mais si vous payez pas la tva la tva
elle va baisser ouf
elle va baisser sur des choses plutôt
marginal attendez il ya 5 milliards de
baisse de tva 5 milliards de trois fois
rien par rapport
combien rapporte la tva monsieur 600
milliards en tout mais alors dans des
contenants de lait il ya 16 milliards de
baisses d impôts dont 5 milliards sur la
terrière et comme l'année dernière il ya
eu aussi des opérations tva au total on
arrive pas loin de 10 milliards bien sûr
par rapport à l'ensemble de la tva vous
avez raison on préférerait tous un monde
dans lequel on fait un souvenir que vous
étiez en campagne et orale vous parliez
de la terreur comme l'impôt le plus
injuste non c'est la taxe d'habitation
mais c'est pas mal pour un jouet à
larrau également injuste et là vous
n'arrivez pas à aller plus loin dans la
baisse de la tva réellement pour les
produits de consommation courante par
exemple les produits de consommation
courante sont taxés à 5,5
si on décide de les taxer à 5% ça coûte
aussi à peu près 4 5 milliards le
problème c'est qu'on sait très bien ce
qui se passe là le prix chez le marchand
ne baisse pas et les différents
intermédiaires commerciaux absorbe le
demi pour cent à demi pour cent de
baisse vous le verriez vous pour que si
on veut que la baie la tva est vraiment
ma poche du consommateur il faut le
faire surtout sur des produits qu'on
contrôle la bonne montée d'edf ça on
sait il va effectivement baisser les
salaires et 130 francs par an soit moins
5 milliards de francs pour l'événement
130 francs par an pour un ménage est
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure monsieur
françois hollande premier secrétaire du
ps dit qu'il faudra peut-être faire un
effort en puces pour les ménages
vous êtes ouvert une négociation pour
aller encore plus loin la vie ne
s'arrête pas maintenant il faut aller
plus loin il faut continuer à essayer de
bca était mais il ne faut pas croire que
n'importe quelle baisse de la tva va
obligatoirement dans la poche des
consommateurs quant à l'autre partie de
baisses d'impôts sur la taxe
professionnelle elle va être à l'origine
de beaucoup d'emplois et c'est comme la
préoccupation principale des français en
même temps vous rognez un peu puisque
vous relever les cotisations maintenant
au total y aura 7 milliards de belles
attaques professionnels alors vous avez
entendu monsieur balladur dimanche
dernier vous souvenez des propos de ce
qu'on disait à propos de monsieur rocard
on disait il profite pas la croissance
il va pas assez loin et monsieur de l'or
récemment tancé un peu grandement disant
aller plus loin
bin moi j'aime tout ce qu'ils me disent
d'aller plus loin parce que ça veut dire
qu'on va dans le bon sens mais qu'il
faut y aller le plus vite possible et on
essaie de le faire
honnêtement une année de croissance
comme on l'a eue la france a bien
travaillé en 98 on aura plus de
croissance que ce qui était prévu
j'entendais tout à l'heure monsieur mais
de la faire la leçon mais au début de
cette année il disait vous n'aurez
jamais la croissance en fait on l'a on
aura même peut-être plus à la fin de
l'année qu'est ce qui était prévu on va
créer trois cent mille emplois
trois cent mille l'année prochaine vous
savez que 300000 emplois
c'est six fois plus que ce qu'on crée
alors une négresse comme 1,3 million de
choses ça effectivement et à falloir du
temps pour arriver au bout et c'est en
créant des emplois qu'on fera baisser le
chômage tout le monde le sait est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas trop optimiste vous
pratiquez vous êtes pratiquement le seul
à dire 2 7% de non non non le grand dans
un scanner prochaine je suis pas le seul
entendu monsieur seillière du tifa de
2,5 me sucer lierse et a déjà trompé
l'année dernière le cd eux la communauté
européenne dit plus que le virus est
elle dit plutôt 3%
moi je dis devenu c'est parce que je
veux qu'on soit prudente l'année
dernière on me faisait le même reproche
au musée vous serez mais je saurai
jamais ni à paris mais on a gagné le
pari alors si on a gagné elle pas une
fois comme on nous fasse crédit pour la
deuxième tendance un budget du
gouvernement on dit toujours il ya des
priorités
mais alors moi j'ai bien regardé les
priorités avec gérard leclerc avec sa
brawn à regarder ça très très près et
puis ben on s'aperçoit vous fait pas
vraiment de priorités vous vous en
donner un petit peu à tout le monde il
ya plein de ministères qui en
bénéficient oui parce qu'il ya plusieurs
priorités et si accomplir est ce que
c'est pas une façon de ne pas choisir
non qu'est ce qu'il ya comme priorités
l'emploi l'éducation la ville la
sécurité l'environnement et
l'antériorité l'autre évidemment ça fait
ça mais il ya quarantaine de sujets et
il ya des sujets sur lequel j'oublie la
justice il ya des sujets sur lequel les
crédits n'augmente pas seulement
ministère par exemple est-ce que
vous vous rendez compte quand même que
nous sommes un des pays qui réduit le
moins son déficit en europe s'il en perd
mais qu est-ce qu on n'avance pas plus
vite pas aussi le talent si vous
permettez sait pas exactement ça on est
à des pays qui réduit le plus sûr
déficit mais comme on est partis de loin
que les autres
on a encore alexis important donc en
effet si la majorité précédente m'avait
pas laissé un déficit au niveau où il
était on serait pas là où on est
aujourd'hui dans la réduction dans
l'effort qui est fait en 98 99
on est à des pays qui réduit le plus son
déficit vrai qu on part de loin et qui a
des choses à rattraper
et c'est normal en 95 on a eu le plus
grand déficit de l'histoire de france et
que cela dure il faut revenir en arrière
gouvernement de monsieur juppé a déjà
commencé à revenir en arrière et puis on
continue
si bien qu'on est encore en retard par
rapport à nos voisins européens mais on
est ce qui faisons le chemin le plus
fort baisse du déficit baisse des impôts
même si elle est encore insuffisante
action pour l'emploi action pour la
justice avec la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation
c'est un budget dans lequel il ya
beaucoup de réformes il y en a une je me
rallierai forme est coincé entre les
petites choses la taxe de la taxe
professionnelle 20 ans qu'on dit que
c'est une taxe idiote
on la réforme elle peut comme en double
dip aux mains supprime un tiers tout ce
qui pèse sur les salaires dont tout ce
qui pèse sur l'emploi et d'ailleurs les
chefs d'entreprise mais peuvent les
salariés semblent bien qu au dessus de
réforme qui est très bien accueillie
dans l'opinion parce que tout le monde
sait que ça fera un emploi une autre
type de réforme
on va supprimer l'obligation de tva pour
les micro entreprises celles qui font
moins de 500 mille francs un chiffre
d'affaires ces 500 une entreprise qui en
bénéficient et vous savez ce que ça va
supprimer comme formalité 15 millions de
formulaires en moins l'année prochaine
15 millions de formulaires remplis par
les français qui n'existeront plus alors
est ce que on dit que vous entendez pas
très bien avec martine aubry
est-ce que vous avez été surpris vexé
que ce soit elle qui soit chargée de
préparer la baisse des charges est ce
que vous êtes favorable cette décharge
d'abord je m'entends très bien avec
martine aubry en dépit d'offres
décideurs à combes et les mauvaises
l'envi ensuite c'est son travail les
charges sociales
moi c'est le budget de la taille les
hapoel c'est les charges sociales avéré
vain mot à dire je suis enfin oui certes
mais enfin c'est à sa centrale de mener
le travail et enfin oui je crois que sur
les bas salaires
vrai problème est que si on peut faire
quelque chose au sein du budget de la
sécurité sociale pour baisser les
charges à bas salaires c'est une bonne
chose
on sait bien qu'une des difficultés
aujourd'hui du chômage sur ceux qui sont
peu qualifiés et c'est cela qu'il faut
aussi d'aider en priorité c'est une
forme de révisions pour les socialistes
qui avaient fait la sourde oreille
une révision s'il s'agit de dire qu'il
faut baisser les charges en général que
le coût du travail en france dans
général trouvé ça ça n'est pas vrai on
est au niveau européen à la moyenne mais
si on parle spécifiquement des bas
salaires là il ya un effort à faire
ça fait très longtemps qu'on est
d'accord merci monsieur strauss kahn
c'est avec nous parce que vous posez une
question sur l'information suivante
c'est une information judiciaire qui a
été ouverte par le parquet de bari sur
la gestion de la mutuelle nationale des
étudiants de france la nef procédure
ouverte contre x à propos des liens
existant entre la nef et des sociétés de
communication la sphère est assez
complexe mais elle concerne une mutuelle
qui assure la couverture sociale de huit
cent vingt mille étudiants et dans le
rapport de la cour des comptes beaucoup
d'infractions ont été relevées certaines
mettant en cause des responsables
socialistes enquête olivier caroff pire
moscovitch pour plus de 800 mille
étudiants la mnef c'est d'abord ceux ci
des prospectus et un stand dans le hall
de la fac synonyme d'inscription à la
sécurité sociale
mais cette mutuelle étudiante intrigue
de plus en plus les pouvoirs publics ce
matin le parquet de paris a ouvert une
information judiciaire pour faux usage
de faux abus de confiance et prise
illégale d'intérêt deux juges
d'instruction vont ainsi s'intéresser
aux marchés de communications passées
entre la mnef et plusieurs sociétés
amies selon la cour des comptes qui a
donné l alerte
elle aurait bénéficié d'un quasi
monopole et facturer leurs prestations
au prix fort
parmi elles paul is it est une
entreprise bien connue de certains
responsables socialistes
elle s'est entre autres occupé de la
campagne pour les municipales de 2 min
strauss kahn
c'était en 1995 parallèlement à cette
instruction la brigade financière va
explorer la mairieà de filiales créées
par la mnef au coeur du système
le directeur général de la mutuelle
olivier spithakis on le retrouve dans de
nombreuses filiales et sociétés privées
dont certaines ont déjà fait l'objet
d'observations de l'administration
c'est le cas par exemple de la multi50
contrôlée par l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales
dans son rapport l'igas s'étonne entre
autres de la présence au conseil
d'administration du président de sos
racisme
fodé sylla une présence rémunérées 5000
francs par mois pour une tâche mal
définis conclusions des inspecteurs de
l'igas
ces éléments jettent un doute sérieux
sur l'utilisation des cotisations
versées par les adhérents olivier
spithakis se dit ce soir surpris de
l'ouverture d'une telle information
judiciaire selon lui l' enquête sur la
nef et ses filiales ne remet pas en
cause la bonne gestion du régime de
protection sociale des étudiants
ce soc cannes vous sentez concerné
puisque le tenons a été citée moi j'ai
effectivement utilisé les services de
cette agence de publicité je peux pas en
dire plus maintenant est-ce qu'ils
avaient le monopole ou pas des actions
de communication de la nef je n'en sais
rien pour moi ils ont fait un bon
travail et il ya d'autres noms de
dirigeants socialistes en citer vous
êtes au courant tout le monde et on lit
la presse on voit qu'il ya un sujet je
pense que s'il ya des questions que
justice doit traiter l les traitera il
est hors de question qu'un régime
étudiant ne fonctionne pas normalement
qu'ils se débattent isation vers des
prestations et s'il ya eu des
irrégularités de fait la justice lui
dire merci beaucoup je devrais juste a
ajouté que le budget de l'audiovisuel
public sera en rose c'est que pour les
téléspectateurs vers une petite
augmentation de la redevance à 744
francs merci à poitiers pendant deux
jours se sont tenues les journées
parlementaires de démocratie libérale
dont le président est monsieur alain
madelin nicolas sarkozy le secrétaire
général du rpr était présent et ensemble
ils ont réaffirmé leur volonté d'une
opposition unie et d'une liste commune
aux élections européennes de l'année
prochaine mais syndicats et les patrons
de l'artisanat du bâtiment qui
représente près de cinq cent mille
salariés devraient signer un protocole
d'accord sur les 35 heures
à noter que les patrons des grandes
entreprises bâtiments seront absents de
cet accord
le mouvement de protestation des
radiologues privés contre la baisse de
leurs tarifs imposées par la ministre
madame aubry à la suite de dérapages
budgétaires ce mouvement se concrétise
dans différentes régions dans les
départements de l'ain
d'or de la moselle et de la vienne est
aussi en charente maritime des
radiologues ont décidé de fermer leur
cabinet il conteste les reproches de
dépassement du nombre d'actes effectués
reportage à la rochelle françois pris 20
philippe ritaine à la rochelle les
médecins radiologues libéraux sont en
grève ce cabinet de radiologie est fermé
depuis trois jours dans les couloirs
chacun exprime sa colère
ici on parle d'un bond de 15 ans en
arrière et on refuse la baisse de 13 5%
imposée par le gouvernement surtout les
actes de radiologie au point d'acheter
une page de publicité dans un quotidien
régional
on ramène l'entreprise à une gestion de
1984 mais avec des frais de 1998 donc
moi je ne connais pas entreprise qui est
capable de gérer une entreprise de cette
façon là une entreprise qu'à 17 salariés
l'entreprise qui est des investissements
en cours qui doit investir dans une
nouvelle chimie je ne sais pas faire
pour ce médecin véritable chef
d'entreprise le remplacement régulier
d'un matériel en constante évolution
reste le principal investissement
si nous voulons maintenir une certaine
une qualité de soins qui est attendu par
nos patients nous sommes obligés de
renouveler très fréquemment notre
matériel de façon à suivre l'évolution
technologique
la caisse primaire d'assurance-maladie
justifie cette mesure par un constat
l'augmentation depuis deux ans des actes
de radiologie
nous avons constaté une augmentation de
9 de plus de 9% tentant montant qu'en
volume 1 on vous l'expliquer mais
justement nous l'expliquent pas on se
pose des questions et c'est certain
qu'il ya une augmentation
inhabituel une augmentation qui nous
pose problème
9 % c'est pourtant l'augmentation de
l'activité d'un centre de radiologie du
secteur public comme celui de l'hôpital
de la rochelle
un centre qui voit le nombre de ses
consultations doublé depuis le début de
la grève des radiologues privés
l'enquète sur les affaires de dopage
dans le cyclisme se poursuit le juge
d'instruction monsieur patrick keil a
fait procéder à l'interpellation d'un
couple de pharmaciens à gap dans les
hautes-alpes
ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir délivré des
produits dopants et peut-être à monsieur
willy voûte le masseur de l'équipe
cycliste festina qui fut interpellé le 8
juillet dernier à la frontière franco
belge alors qu'il transportait des
produits dopants
monsieur vidéo août a été emprisonné
puis libéré il a accepté de s'exprimer
sur son rôle dans cette affaire de
dopage qui concerne les types de richard
virenque reportage philippe visseyrias
christophe vignal à l'intérieur de cette
pharmacie des policiers de la pj
lilloise sont en train de
perquisitionner arrivés vers 8h30 sur
commission rogatoire du juge qu'il les
enquêteurs veulent remonter la filière
d'approvisionnement produits dopants en
fin de matinée le couple de pharmaciens
est interpellé et placé en garde à vue
ce lieu n'est pas anodin nous sommes à
veynes dans les hautes-alpes
là où réside willy voûte le soigneur de
l'équipe festina quelques heures
auparavant
oui les voûtes était à paris chez son
avocat pour la première fois depuis sa
libération il accepte de se confier il
admet avoir transporté pendant des
années des produits dopants à la demande
de son directeur sportif bruno roussel
monsieur roussel il m'a demandé de le
faire sans plus autrement
j'avais peur de perdre en place quoi est
ce que c'est vous qui devient fournir
l'équipe festina en produits dopants
non c'est le docteur qui s'occupaient de
ça est ce que vous savez comment ils
faisaient non je peux pas vous dire
cette entreprise
des bruits il s'agit du docteur jimenez
et surtout du docteur ryke art médecin
de l'équipe festina
ce dernier toujours incarcérés et nie
toute responsabilité dans l'organisation
du dopage
des propos que dément willy voet ça
passait toujours par la docteure même
s'ils n'étaient pas là c'est lui qui m'a
appelé le soir ils me disaient qu'est ce
qu'on devait faire
alors moi j'ai porté dans les chambres
si de bruit ou quoi le docteur donné ses
instructions voilà aujourd'hui
willy vous tu as l'impression d'être
lâché par les siens et surtout par
richard virenque dont il était le master
personnel le coureur nie toujours s'être
dopé et il prétend qu'il n'était pas au
courant des activités illicites de son
masseur est ce que au sein l'équipe
festina et c'était possible que les
coureurs soient dopé à leur insu comme
le prétend ans richard virenque
peut-être non non non oui les voûtes
n'ira pas plus loin mais son avocat nous
montre des carnets sur lesquels le
soigneur aurait inscrit
jour après jour pendant des années tous
les produits dopants pris par les
coureurs de festina
monsieur vous de ces soigneusement
abstenue pour l'instant de révéler le
niveau de dopage auquel monsieur virac
se livrer j'ai bien dit pour l'instant
pas de réaction de la part de richard
virenque
cet après midi sur le tour d'espagne le
leader de l'équipe festina n'était
visiblement pas au courant de ces
derniers développements
dans l' affaire festina le grand
déballage est loin d'être terminée un
autre cycliste français philippe gaumont
de l'équipe cofidis qui participait au
tour d'espagne s'est retiré aujourd'hui
de cette compétition il avait été
contrôlé positif à la nandrolone au mois
de mai dernier
mais il ya controverse sur le taux de
nandrolone au delà duquel on est
considéré comme dopant reportage
nathanaël de rincquesen jacques garnich
dans la précipitation de l'arrivée au
sprint cet après midi à merci philippe
gaumont le coureur de l'équipe cofidis
emporté par son élan a terminé sa course
au pied de sa caravane à ce moment il
n'est pas encore question d'abandon
quatrième au classement général gaumont
a été contrôlé positif il ya cinq mois
selon le monde à l'origine de cette
révélation le français aurait été
alertée samedi de sa positivité par les
instances sportives
les responsables de l'équipe cofidis eu
ni être au courant de quoi que ce soit
faux complètement faux il a rien du tout
il a réfuté un petit peu avec lui de ça
on parle bien évidemment qu'on en parle
mais bon là on n'a aucune information
là-dessus même lui a aucune information
déjà condamné à six mois de suspension
pour dopage en 96 philippe lhomond
risque cinq années de suspension en
garde hassidim jeter mars une lettre à
la maison donc à partir du mois reçoit
web et à la maison
on n'est pas on est parqué positif et
daniel val
le français aurait un taux de nandrolone
naturellement trop élevé selon lui ce
serait la seule explication
si jamais j'avais bricoler comme on peut
dire eh ben je tâcherai n'a pas parlé
mais là je pleure à la tête haute et
regarder tout le monde en face et dire
que j'ai quoi toucher à ce produit là
les dirigeants de l'équipe cofidis n'ont
pas laissé le temps qu'ils vont de
s'expliquer ce soir ils lui ont demandé
de se retirer du tour d'espagne
c'est dans l'orne dans un petit village
nommé sainte honorine la guillaume que
la police a procédé à l'arrestation de
handshaking klein un homme de 51 ans
soupçonné d'avoir été l'un des complices
du terroriste carlos en dessous hacking
klein aurait participé notamment la
prise d'otage des ministres de l'opep à
vienne c'était en 1975 mais depuis ils
s'étaient tenus à l'écart depuis 25 ans
et ils vivent est en france dans l'orne
et puis il y résident et même dans ce
petit village depuis cinq ans reportage
michele finn valérie fournis ou jean
paul miotto non mais franchement moi tu
tiens je viens pas pour les gens du
village
il s'appelait dire qu'il était
journaliste nous avait dit qu'il s'était
retiré ici parce qu'avec les appareils
qu'ils avaient maintenant pour y
travailler à distance entre la france
l'allemagne a depuis travaillé pour lui
travailler pour un journal allemand hans
joachim klein avait choisi il y a cinq
ans de s'installer dans ce village de
l'orne
en fait il se cachait en france depuis
20 ans en 1995 le visage dissimulé
derrière une fausse barbe il s'était
confié à des journalistes
comment tu vis aujourd'hui je survis
c'est déjà pas si mal
je dois me cacher de la police je me
cachais de beaucoup d'autres gens de qui
mais l'ancien soit des amis lorsqu'il
évoque ses anciens amis
kaïn pense d'abord à carlos en 1975 à
vienne il organise avec lui la prise
d'otage des ministres de l'opep
trois otages sont tués klein est
grièvement blessée au ventre
le commando demande qu'un avion soit
mise à sa disposition et s'échappe avec
les otages en 1994 carlos est arrêté au
soudan la police judiciaire allemande
elle ne cessera jamais de surveiller
l'entourage de en sus à qui mme klein
vendredi dernier elle a transmis à la
police française le renseignement qui
lui a permis d'arrêter 23 ans après la
prise d'otages
l'ancien lieutenant de carlos il y à
quelques heures à washington le
président américain bill clinton lors
d'une rencontre organisée à la maison
blanche avec des dirigeants du parti
démocrate son parti a renouvelé ses
excuses et ses demandes de pardon la
suite de la firme monica levinsky
monsieur clinton craint que certains
élus démocrates l'abandonnent
commentaires à washington de philippe
gassot pour bill clinton les semaines
qui s'annoncent seront difficiles voire
décisives
le temps se couvre pour la première fois
le président est tué et les banderoles
des missions fleurissent les
responsables démocrates qui ont tendance
à se défausser en ce moment ont été
invités ce matin à la maison blanche
autour du président un seul mot d'ordre
resté silencieux au moins jusqu'à la
publication du rapport
kenneth starr les démocrates tentent de
resserrer les rangs au resort vous avons
une entrevue avec le président ce matin
nous avons vu c'est un père un mari le
chef de notre pays qui regrette vraiment
désolé de la réunion n'aura fait oublier
cependant à personne les déclarations de
ces derniers jours dans les rangs
démocrates
elles font penser au début que la curée
il s'agit pour certains notables de ne
pas couler lors des élections de
novembre prochain avec le président en
ayant ce type de relation le président a
commis une erreur
objectivement sa crédibilité est
sévèrement diminuée
ce n'est pas seulement une question de
conduite inappropriée sa conduite n'est
pas seulement inappropriée
elle est immorale
tous ces témoignages proviennent de
démocrates qui tiennent à se démarquer
du président au congrès autour du
speaker on attend le rapport de kenneth
starr le président aussi le document ne
devrait omettre aucun détail
une chanson événements proposés par
michel sardou une chanson intitulée
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait moi
référence à l'attitude que nous aurions
eu les uns les autres si nous avions
vécu pendant la dernière guerre michel
sardou bonsoir la quantité du chanteur
engagé c'est ça non pas vraiment je ne
sais pas je dirais que c'est pas une
question qu'on s'est posée jean loup
dabadie et moi puisqu'il a collaboré à
au texte avec moi et on se dit
finalement 50 ans de paix c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de france
qu'on a ça donc on n'est pas habitué aux
ténèbres qu'ont connu nos pères et nos
grands pères et qu'est ce qu'on aurait
été nous avec une information truqués ou
très peu d'informations quels choix on
aurait fait quel courage on aurait eu là
c'est pas une sanction sur le passé j'ai
pas voulu une chanson sur ce qui a été
fait pendant l'occupation parce qu'une
chanson c 32 lignes donc on peut dire
beaucoup de choses en termes de lignes
mais pas raconter une époque
j'allais dire c'est presque une
réflexion chanter voilà un extrait de
cette chanson et puis quelques
commentaires de bruno roger petit qui
vous avez suivi notamment
oui jusqu'à de le voir sans caméra
derrière moi n'est proposée aux
téléspectateurs de france veut survivre
tenait jusque là enfoui au plus profond
de ses tiroirs thèmes abordés résistance
et collaborations question qu'est ce
qu'il aurait fait lui
pour ceux qui sont nés aujourd'hui
choisir le bon côté c'est sûr vous
voulez sauver leur vie
beaucoup s'inclinaient par nature
quelle sorte d'homme aurais-je été celui
du rail du vercors ou bien ce gamin
abusé gens à la guerre dont à l'amour
il y a quelques mois pour cause de
procès papon parce que sartoux et sardou
genre avec ma grande gueule je mets les
pieds dans le plat
le chanteur et ses proches avaient
renoncé à interpréter ça trop dangereux
si lui l'avait sortie étant donné ce
qu'il est sardou permettant de faire ça
ça eut encore il y avait aucun problème
du répercussions ça nous prend la
défense de donc ce n'est beaucoup de
matches sans lui et moi justement peau
pour être le plus le plus droit possible
moins ambiguë possible qu'ils aient pas
deux mais il y aura toujours un conte
pour vous dire à la chanson sur les
collabos c'est sûr je pense à tous les
humiliés par cette étoile qui l'ont
portée parce que ça s'est passé chez moi
je pense sont ce qu'ils sont plus là
pour
notre avenir
la mémoire n'est pas dépassé
elle part demain
pas mon gars
est ce que j'aurai tellement
michel sardou prend encore une fois le
risque de déplaire il y a ceux qui
aimeront et il y aura les autres comme
d'habitude
dans le cd qui sort vous avez déjà un
début de réponse qu'est ce que vous
auriez fait c'est en voyant procès papon
c'est en lisant les noms océan je vais
lui l'histoire de france sous
l'occupation comme tout le monde va
comme beaucoup de gens j'ai lu je suis
un passionné d'histoire donc j'ai laissé
cette période je veux dire c'est pas le
fait de se poser la question je n'aime
pas de réponse dans la chanson mais je
crois que le fait de se poser la
question aujourd'hui est déjà un début
de réponse et vous le fait la qualité
d'homme qu'on a deux générations oui
c'est surtout ce sont les plus jeunes
qui sont les plus jeunes aussi comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure cette période
de paix tu est incroyable dans
l'histoire de france sur notre sol du
mois on n'a jamais connu ça mais la
guerre est partout
la guerre est donc dans le monde entier
on regarde nos journaux et on livre les
jambes on lit les journaux en garde
journaux télévisés la guerre est partout
rien n'indique que rien ne peut nous
garantir qu'un cannes affrontement
sérieux quelque part ne dégénère en une
guerre totale en une guerre absolue
comme aurait dit alain decaux et à ce
moment là qu'est ce qu'on sera quelle
sorte qu'elle sorte d'homme vous serez
vous moi je savais la presse est ce que
vous pensez qu'on a raison de faire
certains procès où est ce qu'il faudrait
oublier non angolais ne mélangeons pas
tout faire les process il faut les faire
ces hommes ont commis des crimes
impardonnables et je dis dans la chanson
le pardon ne suffit pas il faut
absolument les condamnés parce que
genappe sourit un jeune juge rien dans
la chanson je vous rappel c'est un homme
de ma génération qui n'y étaient pour
rien n'est pas mêlé à cela il faut faire
des procès ne serait ce que pour se
souvenir faut savoir que ça s'est passé
que des hommes apparemment sains de
corps et l'esprit normaux mis en balle
il d'un papier oui envoyez-moi tendre
personnes dans un camp de concentration
quelque part où ils savaient très bien
que la mort les attendait ça il faut
absolument faire les procès mais ça
c'est une chose c'est les historiens
c'est les juges de la justice mme je
suis un artiste
bon les j'aurais agi en artiste et je me
pose la question donne à l'homme
artistes qui se dit et moi un artiste
pendant la guerre est ce que j'aurais
fait qu'elle ait keller que l'arrêt vous
êtes un terme aux attitudes j'ai pas de
réponse mais je me pose la question
c'est déjà un signe un signe
oui c'est une partie de la réponse
michel ça pourquoi est-ce que de temps
en temps comme ça vous avez envie de
dire des choses fortes dur difficile
quelquefois par rapport à des séries de
chansons qui sont plus populaire plus
dense en plus joyeuse et qu'est ce qui
fait que quand t'en sers 12-10 tient là
je vais vraiment foncer un coin parce
que j'ai envie de me disent que le 10
mai grande gueule mais c'est pas
seulement ma grande gueule c'est que de
temps en temps je vois que la chanson
peut être autre chose qu'un
divertissement tout en restant à
divertissement les et puis dire
peut-être quelque chose qui nous aidera
à réfléchir ou à faire penser comme une
pièce comique ou comme un très bon film
mais on peut très bien sortir de sortir
d'un film se dire tiens j'avais pas
pensé à cela merci à michel merci michel
salmon être venu nous présenter cette
chanson je voudrais dire qu on vous
retrouve chez ce michel drucker d'un
tapis rouge la première de tapis rouge
c'est samedi prochain c'est à 20h50 sur
c'est là où on est avec vous surprendre
merci beaucoup je vous rappelle la fin
de ce journal quelques unes des
principales informations que nous avons
développé la mise en cause du rôle de
l'état dans le rapport parlementaire sur
la corse présente très pernicieux de la
vanille le budget pour l'emploi selon le
gouvernement mais jacques chirac a
marqué sa différence
le soigneur belge de festina l'équipe
cities qui dévoile les pratiques de
dopage de son équipe
richard virenque pourrait être remise en
cause
voilà pour l'information dans un instant
la suite avec la météo d'isabel martinez
sera perturbé et frais demain à 21h le
choix d'une mère un téléfilm avec isabel
otero à zéro heure 35 dernier journal de
bruno roger petit ce sera juste après
jean claude ory jean luc delarue et puis
demain 7h50 françoise laborde pour les 4
vérités recevra christian paul député ps
de la nièvre à 13 heures demain carole
gaessler rachid arhab à demain 20h
bonsoir merci